[Music]
[Applause]
Irma Edwards former head coach College
in the NFL he appears in the new uh
football theme show Monday Blitz at 3
Eastern on the mothership as well as
Sports Center and ESPN radio as well
good morning Herm let me start there
who's to blame for this mess in Chicago
oh boy um you can kind of spread it
around I think when you look at this
football team play
um
you know they're still in in the mode of
trying to rebuild uh obviously the
offensive line defensively they've
struggled the last couple years uh have
a quarterback that's unique and in the
sense that um
he's you know he's basically I hate to
say this in pro football now that we
have RPO quarterbacks and uh what you do
with them the style of offense you run
with them is very important I think he
made light of it um in his press
conference I think he walks some things
back but but basically you know this is
what happens in pro football a lot
coaches come in with systems and their
system is bigger than the player well if
you want to be a successful coach you
have to massage your system around the
player skill set yeah but it feels like
we've seen coaches adapt to that that
they know I'm not going to ask you to be
different if I'm coaching Cam Newton I
gotta let Cam Newton be Cam Newton or
Michael Vick or Patrick Mahomes and this
situation is interesting because usually
that third year you see the quarterback
start to make that you know progression
like all of a sudden you go okay you
gonna make that jump or are you not
going to make that jump but I'm
wondering
how would you coach how would you coach
Justin fields
well obviously I'm going to allow him to
use his legs that's going to be part of
the passing game uh you know that they
they try to do it a little bit last year
and I think what they were worried about
he ran so much
you know he ran for over 1100 yards I
mean it's a quarterback I mean that's
you know those are numbers like you
scratch your head at I I think our
vision of him would be similar to Jalen
Hurst what he's been able to do uh as a
quarterback you know still has the
ability to run uh it can throw the ball
he's more comfortable in the pocket now
and and that's the case when you watch
Justin Fields I mean last week he
watched it is almost like a statue in
the pocket uh decision making when to
get the ball out you know he he
struggles with that sometimes
quarterbacks they're timing their Rhythm
you got to get them going early in the
game and those are the things that I
think going into this week you'll see
from Chicago Bears yeah but now you got
Kansas City oh boy you know you can't
beat Green Bay you can't beat Tampa Bay
and now all of a sudden you got the
Chiefs who are fully assembled with
Chris Jones and Travis Kelsey and is he
is he just gonna go all right I'm going
back to the way I did last year I'm just
going to run and try to create something
here and not stay in the pocket I think
you'll see more of that this week
um he'll he'll leave obviously uh when
he feels uh he can move the chains and
and I think for quarterbacks like this
and you don't understand if you watch
football a long time as well you got to
get them started you know early in this
game they've got to see some completions
to get them confident that that's any
quarterback and I think how you design
that is very important
um his mechanisms you know generally you
dial up a play and there's always a
check down his check down is his legs
okay if it's not open you know what take
off man go ahead and and um you know
that's why that's what we did with with
Jaden Daniels his freshman year when he
played for us at Arizona State you know
it was like the check down is your legs
man you know if it if you're not there
go ahead and go
well you can do that in college I I
think Justin Fields is trying to out
athlete
defenses and you can't do that in
college you can do that at Ohio State
you can do that you can't do that it's
not sustainable there I think that's
what would concern me if I'm I'm the
Bears you passed up on you know Bryce
young you know you traded that number
one pick here's your guy and at some
point you're going to have to extend him
or you have to move on from him this
would be a big year for them
you know through this season how he
finishes and and if he continues to
develop
um they'll be fine if not that's the
question they're gonna have to ask
yourself yeah I was wondering if you're
Caleb Williams
and you're going I could go to the Bears
or I could go to the Cardinals
and these quarterbacks have to realize
um you get picked number one you're
probably going to go to a team you know
that that didn't win a lot of games and
and that's you can dodge it and say well
I'm gonna stay another year a lot of
these guys can because of uh the money
they can get for the name image and like
if they stay in college longer that that
that's maybe the good thing about
college football guys can stay in a
little longer if they if they choose to
right or you could pull an Eli Manning
and just say look I I don't want to go I
don't want to go to your organization
yeah that'd be interesting
talking to Herm Edwards the former
player coach college and the NFL how do
you explain what Dion has done and and
can it be replicated around the country
there's only one Deion Sanders there's
no doubt about that Dion's a good friend
um I'm enjoying it like everyone else
he's brought national attention to his
program along with with a team that is
very exciting right he's got some really
good players it's a shame about the kid
Hunter
I thought you know the way he was
playing if he continued at this pace
he's got to be talked about as a Heisman
guy who who does that who plays 160
plays uh in a football game I mean I
could see anything like that I mean he's
a phenomenal athlete but
he's brought national attention Dion
um no matter if you're a Colorado
Buffalo fan or not you want to see these
guys play I mean it's it's funny and his
son is a tremendous player now I mean
boy he can play quarterback now and and
so it's it's something that's unique
um I don't think you can replicate it uh
because there's only one Deion Sanders
now what you can replicate is this he he
understands the portal he understands
there's free agency in college football
now how you build your team you're going
to have to kind of go outside the walls
you know there's free agency you you
have the ability to bring players in
could you see Dion coaching in the NFL
one day
I'll be interested
um I I think his aspirations might be to
do that later on
um
it it would it would be very interesting
but what's the biggest difference with
that Herm
well you know his Persona how he's going
about getting these young guys excited
and you know all the the rah-rah that's
in college football pro football and
Dion knows this he was a great player
Hall of Famer maybe he's the best corner
to ever played a game in my my opinion
um how you handle that with with NFL
players you know you're going to have an
old group of guys you're gonna have some
young group of guys that can buy into
what he's doing the old couple guys will
just say look man I don't want to hear
all that right so but but I think he's
smart enough to know if he gets to that
level
um he'll handle it he'll be able to
handle him and I didn't think this would
be their year I thought it would be next
year
um and now they go to Oregon they got
USC right how sustainable do you think
this is for Dion well I think this I
think Oregon will be a really be a
really good game for them to see where
they're at
SC
I believe this
um I don't see sc's defense
I don't know if it's improved that much
yeah so you can score
and it could be a scoring game against
SC right I mean that's that's how you
look at it and they'll see it makes no
bones I mean with that quarterback you
could score as many as you want
right and that offense they have boys
that's fun to watch too I mean you you
won't be able to sit down I mean if if
you go like go get a snack you might
somebody might score a touchdown time
you leave and come back right but um
this would be an interesting two weeks
for him where do you put Micah Parsons
now as great Defenders oh boy not just
in the game now but is he starting to
slip into a different category that's
the talk I won't say he is as I won't
say he has taken the throne away from 56
that played for the Giants you know who
that is
I was just with him about a month ago
but but you saw LT a young LT well who's
my hero yeah yeah we played against each
other and uh how would you describe that
oh he wrecked the game but he physically
correct the game too that's the
difference
I see LT was
and it's because he's bigger he was a
big man that could run and could just
you know Lou but but he was physical
I mean he could physically dominate you
it was a scary physicalness uh with LT
and so Michael Parsons is is
unbelievable though I mean his ability
sixty percent of the time
sixty percent of the time he beats
one-on-one the average in the National
Football League is 17 percent he's
winning at a 60 percent rate
that's unheard of I mean the whole
league is at 17. he's at 60.
I yeah I don't know I'd figure out how
World number 11 is that I'd send two
guys at it for sure well remember Joe
Gibbs did that with LT he make sure that
you brought the you kept the tight end
and you know you know I had Joe Jacoby
there because yeah if not then you know
you got trouble in the backfield no no
doubt but the problem now in football
you know it college is is really taken
over in the NFL too um
you don't see two tight ends hardly
anymore yeah you know you don't see two
running backs I mean you see three wide
receivers four wide receivers uh one
tight end three wide receivers one back
and that's what you see they spread you
out because if not the receivers are
getting mad right you got to deal with
these receivers that want the ball every
other play they're seven eleven they're
always open that's what they tell you on
the sideline hey coach I'm hoping man
okay we'll get you the ball we get it
right I was talking about Dan Marino
yesterday I think at the end of your
career you faced Marine oh I played
against him yes
um I I keep saying he if I could play
the position I would want to play the
way he played the position because he
just he was ahead of his time what he
did you know five wide empty backfield
and let's you know there that's what you
have in college high school announced
some of the NFL teams
not more
they had them all right I had to cover
them I was trying to cover those guys oh
he's unbelievable that quarterback
maybe one of the he's in the top
three
quarterbacks ever play in my opinion the
way he got the ball out his accuracy his
arm talent I mean it was just it I I
remember when he came in the league I
said who is it we you know Washington
College and all of a sudden you're
playing against then all of a sudden you
got duper you got Clayton you got Matt
Moore I mean it's like oh boy here who
are these guys right we had to play them
and we had a great defense of
Philadelphia yeah but they they gave us
they they gave they made us work
Jimmy cefalo was in the slot too don't
get up oh yeah Penn State Jimmy seffola
yeah yeah they had a good crew uh how
you doing you doing all right I'm good
yeah I'm good yeah traveling on the
weekends obviously leaving going back to
the Mothership as you mentioned yeah in
there on Sundays Mondays and you know a
little bit Tuesday and come home so but
I'm good my girls are growing up I I got
one that's a senior now
um looking at colleges she's a
journalist major so she's in a couple
spots you know tell her to tell her to
get into another field than that you
know it's too late it's too late I was
watching the video of when you walked
off the field when you were told that
you got fired like we're talking about
those like Lane kiffin getting fired
right on the tarmac there uh I mean what
goes through your mind and somebody is
is filming this when you're walking on
yeah but you have any idea that was
happening no no no and that was more
that wasn't that that's not that
statement and people said that you know
he talked about I got fired at night now
okay now that wasn't it at all we we
always meet there we always talk they
didn't and the president and no
that it wasn't that didn't happen like
people make it to be well see you can
you can tell your daughter how the media
takes stories and then they uh
[Laughter]
where they don't let you get on the bus
coach and after a loss yeah and I'm
happy for Lane you know Lane was with us
in Tampa when he was a young kid he was
the ball boy when we were down in Tampa
Bay mining was Monty was his father
Monty was the coordinator
um I was the assistant head coach lovey
was the linebacker coach Rod Marinelli
was the d-line coach we had a crew of
really good coaches and then when I left
to go to New York Tomlin took my spot so
Lane was on the sideline it's a young
kid growing up I remember laying when he
was you know in high school so did you
think at any point that guy would be a
head coach
you know you wondered because because
when you're just watching them grow up
you know Nathaniel Hackett Nathaniel
Hackett was the ball boy up in New York
with me uh with Paul you know Paul I
mean Paul was uh he was listen to this
that's how far we go back I mean when I
went to Cal as a freshman
Paul Hackett was the ga
grad assistant yes account Berkeley
that's how far I go back with Paul and
then when I wanted to run the West Coast
offense in New York I hired Paul you
know because he was with Walsh and all
those guys that run my offense but Chad
Pennington right and Nathaniel And my
son were playing there were like the
ball boys
you stay in this league long enough for
you you know and John Gruden was a ball
boy at Notre Dame yeah yeah yeah
unbelievable how it works good to talk
to you I guess that's the thing is you
got to start out as a ball boy that's
how you become a head coach in the NFL
yes hey yeah you know this then just
kind of hang around and all of a sudden
you know things happen you know
good good to talk to you thank you buddy
always my friend thank you that's Herman
Edwards you can see him on the
mothership new football theme show
Monday Blitz three Eastern on uh ESPN
also appearances on uh get up and Sports
Center